foreign
good afternoon
if everybody's ready we will proceed I
see one person sitting okay
good afternoon I'm Attorney Ben Crump
along with attorney Ray Hanlon and Chris
O'Neal
attorney to be high share an attorney
Desiree Austin
we have present with us
two of the daughters of Malcolm and
Betty Shabazz we have
eliasis sebast and kubila Savage present
with us
15 years ago today
In This Very Room
one of the greatest thought leaders
ever
known in the 21st century
was assassinated
and since that time
there has been
speculation
as to who was involved
in the
assassination of Malcolm X
we know
on November 18th
it was
confirmed and substantiated
that
government agencies
the New York Police Department
the FBI
the district attorney of New York
had factual evidence
a sculptory evidence
that they fraudulently concealed
from the men
who were wrongfully
convicted
for the assassination of Malcolm X
and they also fraudulently concealed
that information
most importantly
from the family of Malcolm X
we know
that based
on their wrongful conviction
that the government settled
the matter
of Mr azir and Mr ism
Mr Aziz
for tens of millions of dollars
this is important for many reasons
one of the most important reasons it
gives
Malcolm's daughters
opportunity
to seek legal redress
finally
based on
the governments admission that they
conceal
evidence
involving the assassination of Malcolm X
the truth
of what happened
and who was involved
has always been critical
so today
at the Malcolm X and Dr Betty stabas
Memorial and Educational Center
we announced
and get former notice
to the city of New York
the state of New York
and the federal government
and its agencies the FBI and the CIA
that
the family members
intend to sue
bring a wrongful death lawsuit
based on these new Revelations
that have now finally been substantiated
and the rhetorical question
is this
if the government
compensated
the two gentlemen that were wrongfully
convicted
for the assassination of Malcolm X
with tens of millions of dollars
than what
is
to be the compensation
for
the daughters
who suffered the most
from the assassination of Malcolm X
we intend to
have vigorous
litigation of this matter
to have discovery
to be able to take depositions
of the individuals who
are still alive
58 years later
to make sure
that some measure of Justice
can be given
to Malcolm X's daughters
who In This Very Room
were present
with their mother
when he was shot
at 21 times 17 bullets hitting him
if anybody deserves
Justice
after these decades
it is these women
at this time
my
most able co-counsel who has been a
champion for justice on many fronts who
I'm proud to stand with
as we take on this historical
Endeavor for justice
we'll address you
and then you will hear remarks
by
one of Malcolm's daughters
but I give you
my co-counselor
my friend my brother attorney Ray Hamlin
from New Jersey
thank you good afternoon
when you think back all those years ago
58 years ago
as attorney Trump mentioned
there were two people here
that fateful day
two young girls
at the time
who are now women
and for decades and decades and decades
have had to live
with the trauma of that day
they had a choice
the choice was to
do nothing
or to do something
they have chosen
to do something
after all these years
and after confirmation
that those who are responsible
laid in the
town halls in the city halls and
government buildings
that for reasons
that only they know
decided that it was best
to try and conspire to withhold
information this critical information
that would have given the family some
modicum of relief
but since that didn't happen
58 years later
we're going to make sure that the family
finally gets that modicum of relief that
they justly deserve
and with that said
I will turn it back over to uh
Mr Chrome
sure
I'm gonna have uh one of Malcolm's
daughters
and on behalf of
kabila Shabazz who is here who is going
to proceed with this lawsuit ilyasa
Shabazz is going to proceed with this
lawsuit Camilla Shabazz
Malika Shabazz who passed away her
daughter is going to be a part of this
section as well as relax
we look forward to this opportunity
to pursue this matter
finally
thank you very much attorney Hamlin
thank you
you know
this was a great Injustice
that was done to this family
these daughters
who
in many ways because
the fraudulent concealment of the truth
we're in a different kind of prison
nobody can imagine
where they've had to endure
and so for this great Injustice
we will be filing
a wrongful death lawsuit against these
governmental entities for 100 million
dollars
on behalf
of his daughters that are coming forward
but there is no measure of money
there is no measure
uh
explanation
that they could ever offer this family
the only thing they can do
is try to write a historic wrong
not just for his family
but for
his people
in this world
we have to write this historic wrong
so at this time you will hear from
Malcolm's daughter
ilyasa sebast
on February 21st 1965
my mother came here excited to see her
husband
because a week prior
her home had been firebombed
she walked in here happy and she left
out chattered
today
we will celebrate our father's Life and
Legacy with the community because it is
something that my mother did every year
that for as long as I can remember
with my sisters and and just the larger
Community we will also seek Justice
for a man a very young man who's only 39
years old
who gave his life for human rights
for years our family has fought for the
truth to come to light concerning his
murder
and we'd like our father
to receive the justice that he deserves
the truth about the circumstances
leading to the death of our father is
important not only to his family but to
many followers many admirers many who
look to him
for guidance for love
and it is our hope that litigation of
this case will finally provide some
unanswered questions
we want Justice served for our father
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much ilyassa
at this time we will take a few of your
questions
if you have any
where it was admitted to that's why they
paid 36 million dollars to the two
gentlemen were wrongfully convicted
you can get with the District Attorney's
Office in the city who
admitted that these gentlemen were
wrongfully convicted and that there was
a sculpture evidence that would have
exonerated them that they did not
uh release or reveal and
there are many things that will be put
forth in our lawsuit
that speaks
to
this factual evidence
things that many people have
speculated over the decades but were not
substantiated
we believe that now it could be
substantiated based on the recent
exonerations
of those who were wrongfully convicted
remember
Diego Hoover
the head of the FBI said
on
June 5th
1964.
do something about Malcolm X
in less than a year
he was assassinated
we think that the truth will finally
come to light
and this family will finally get the
legal redress that was due to them so
many decades ago
talking about Justice delay
well we
plan on taking depositions of many of
the figures that were involved
uh either rightfully or wrongfully
in the assassination of Malcolm X
it's not just about the trigger man
it's also about those
who conspired with the trigger man
to do this dastardly deed
that killed
that 39 year old young father
where we believe we'll be able with the
force of law
to subpoena and depose any individual
that has relevant information
that's what has never happened
in the
aftermath of the assassination of
Malcolm X
Martin Luther King's family
had a legal
proceeding
where there were people put on the oath
and because of the rule of law
they were compelled to give testimony
you had that with Fred Hampton's family
but we never had that with Malcolm X's
family
and just like
there are many who believed
Martin Luther King was killed as
a result of a conspiracy about the
federal government
and the local governmental entities
as well as Fred Hampton
with the federal government and the
local governmental entities working in
concert with one another it is also
believed that Malcolm X was assassinated
at the will of governmental entities on
the local level and the federal level
and we believe that them concealing
this information
is a big step in being finally able to
reveal the truth of what happened in the
conspiracy to kill Malcolm X I didn't
know if you want that
the fact that this wrongful death
watches are you suggesting or claiming
that these government agencies were
involved in the conspiracy to
assassinate compliments that is what we
are a legend yes
those are still officially inclusive why
do we feel that this case will lead to a
conclusion and is Minister Farrakhan
still bought
as part of the information you're trying
to get at
we're going to make sure that we follow
the evidence where it leaves and we have
sued the federal government and their
entities because they infiltrated many
of and we have evidence that they
infiltrated
many civil rights organizations
to be able to destroy them and destroy
the leaders I think
Diego Hoover referred to them that we
must not have a black Messiah
after he made sure that Marcus Garvey
was convicted of federal crimes that was
always his greatest fear and as as is
well documented and you asked the
question about Martin Luther King's
family and Fred Hampton's family and
they've been in have been inconclusive
however in both of those cases the
federal government
paid money
which is
in many ways an admission
that you were involved somehow
and so
however they admitted
this would be a landmark case whether
they
compensate the family or we go to
verdict
uh we're looking at every aspect into
the assassination of Malcolm X yes
the CIA
where
Amy we we are
going to talk to those individuals
who were wrongfully convicted not just
of their assassination but in the days
leading up to the assassination that we
believe this was an orchestrated effort
and so what we have to do is connect the
dots
and
you know as people get older as they get
ready to meet their maker
the hope is that they would look at
Malcolm X's daughters
and say
we wronged them
and we need to make that right before we
leave this earth just to be clear
because you say you're saying you're
talking about a conspiracy you're saying
the conspiracy include the FBI the CIA
and the Manhattan D.A their conspiracy
included many many individuals and many
many government entities and agencies
and many
Affiliates of those agencies
we'll keep you informed and we will
certainly provide you with our notice uh
press at Ben crump.com will get the
notice to you
four four
and two years old and unborn twins today
below is four thank you thank you